identification of novel biomarkers or
thyroid cancer through multi-omics data
analysis
hello everyone my name is cheena dhingra
and i am a research fellow at pine
biotic i am a post graduation
postgraduate student at amity university
noida i have also done my bachelors of
science in biotechnology from amateur
university noida
the objective of my project is analysis
through artificial intelligence build
platform utilizing algorithms and tools
for multi omics data analysis
the contents which i will covering
through this presentation are
introduction data review methodology
results discussion conclusion and
references
thyroid cancer is the thyroid cancer is
a condition in which cancer cells
originate in all the thyroid in the
thyroids gland tissue thyroid nodules
are prevalent although they aren't
always cancerous
thyroid cancer comes in a variety of
forms thyroid cancer risk is influenced
by age gender and radiation exposure
thyroid cancer thyroid tumor is most
common type of tumor it accounts for one
to five percent of human tumor the
thyroid is present in a gland gland of
the neck that produces two hormones
called tyrosine and
tritoxin t4 and
t3 these hormone health the body
helps the body to produce energy
required by the cells and to function
the body properly apart from these
hormones thyroid glands also produce
calcitonin that helps to locate
to regulate the amount of blood calcium
there are four types of thyroid cancer
papillary carcinoma
these types of thyroid cancer growth
grow slowly
occur from follicular sense these type
of cancer can be cured easily with the
help of medication
follicular thyroid carcinoma are also
the most common type of thyroid cancer
it occurs when there is less amount of
iodine in the body follicular thyroid
calcinoma is more likely to subject to
organs and other parts of the body than
papillary carcinoma medullary thyroid
cancer developed from the c cells in the
thyroid gland these type of cancers are
less differentiated as compared to the
other two cancer and can easily spread
in lymph nodes in other parts of the
body
if amount of
calcitonin is more in the blood than
there is a high chance of medullary
carcinoma present in the blood four type
of
thyroid cancer is anaplastic thyroid
cancer that is the most common type of
thyroid carcinoma but the most
restrictive form of thyroid cancer it
spreads easily to neck and other parts
of the body anaplastic thyroid cancer
can also be treated by the surgery and
this has less survival rate as compared
to other three thyroid carcinoma
thyroid cancer can be due to too many
factors age gender external radiation
and diet
the expression data
data review the expression data is
stored in the form of microarray data in
geo gene expression omnibus the data is
derived from different patients
suffering from different types of cancer
and their subtypes by using the
microarray expression profile one can
easily identify specific biomarkers and
biological pathway related to it
the gene expression omnibus includes ceo
database data sets a library of gene
expression
this
the microarray analysis techniques are
used to evaluate data from dna rna and
protein microarray investigation which
allow researchers to explore the
expression say expression state of a
large number of genes
methodology uh first the dataset
gse3467
gsc3678 and gsc
33630 and gsc
353157 was found from the geo database
the corresponding matrix files of all
the four datasets were downloaded and
stored for further analysis with the
help of different bioinformatics tools
differentially expressed genes for
analyzed and interpreted for all the
four data sets the data in this four
data sets were present in the form of
microarray data microarray data is
usually normalized so here no quant
quantile globalization was performed the
corresponding files for the four data
sets were introduced to excel in order
to find differentially expressed genes
and set data ready for analysis all the
duplicates id was cleaned out and also
all the zeros were cleaned out of the
data in excel t-test was performed
between the means of two group normal
thyroid sample and thyroid cancer sample
thus p value for all the pro parties
were calculated along with p existed
value locked to four j thus we could
identify up regulator differentially
expressed genes from all the four data
sets
these probe ids are matched with their
corresponding gene symbol
downloaded from the platform gpl 570
that is same for all the four data sets
geo session id the matching of the genes
with the probe ids was to form using r
studio using left join function
to find the common differentially
expressed gene between the two dataset
left join function was
used in r studio heat maps were also
prepared for the degrees
this is for all this is to find a
differentially expressed analysis pca
from principal component analysis was
also performed to find the highest
highest variability between the genes
secondly biological interpretation was
done by using many
bioinformatics tools present online
differentially expressed analysis the
series matrix file for all the four data
sets were downloaded using geo data base
and nextly they were introduced to excel
now the t test value were calculated
along with the corresponding
adjusted p value locked to four chains
for all the four data sets the values
were filter out to find the number of up
regulated genes using our studios gene
symbols and platform text file gpl 570
were matched to the corresponding probe
ids in this table we can we can see the
jio session id of
the four data sets along with a number
of uh tumor samples normal to a normal
thyroid sample and tumor thyroid samples
along with the number of probiotics
inner joint function was also performed
to see the number of common genes here
we could see that only 40 their highest
number of common genes between the two
data sets are 40 and with
no number of no common genes found
between gsc 3678 and gsc mgsc3467
data sets
clustering
data heat maps for all the four data
sets were prepared using c map software
here we can
see that the regula the heat map was
only performed for the top upregulated
genes for all the four data sets here we
can see that they were differentially
expressed in the
two sample in the two samples normal
thyroid sample and thyroid cancer
samples
upset plot was prepared using our studio
to find number of intersecting genes 74
genes were found to be common to at
least two data sets and 13 genes were
found to be common to three data sets
these upregulated integrated
but for use for further analysis
pca
principal component analysis is a
process of computing the principal
component and using them to change the
basis of the data
often simply using the first viewing
disk regarding the res pc was performed
on the four data set individually
pc was performed using t by info server
under the section utilities the result
for pc was present in the form of text
file the text file was opened using
excel and scatter plot for the two
highest variability for all the four
data sets for prepared
pc interpretation for the data set
gse3678 highest variability is seven
point four two percentage and eighteen
point nineteen percentage so so a
scattered plot was prepared for all the
for the values of these data variables
these two variables red color indicates
thyroid cancer samples and blue color
for normal thyroid samples gst 33630
showed the highest availability of 27.39
percentage and 12.255 percentage for the
gse 353157
data set highest variability is 19.51
percentage and 11.46 percentage for the
gst 3467 data set highest variability is
minus 29.98 percentage and minus 15.0
percentage
david
the database for annotation
visualization and integrated discovery
provides investigators with a complete
collection of functional annotation
tools to help them comprehend the
biological significance of enormous list
of genes
using functional annotation tool in
david genontology g over done for the
integrated upregulated genes gene on
autology was divided into three parts
biological process cell composition and
molecular function it was found that
most of the up regulated genes were
involved in protein binding plasma
membrane and integral component of
plasma membrane less genes are focused
on endoplasmic reticulum and
protein homody marriage
homodyzation
activity as shown in the figure p value
in the count of every geo terms is
present in the table below
integrated gene pathway was also
performed using david pathway analysis
of the integrated upregulated genes was
also performed using david functional
annotation 2
pathways were divided into six
categories
most of the appreciated genes were
involved in epithelial domes mesenchymal
transition and colorectal cancer tgf
beta signaling pathway
neutrophil d granulation and
extracellular matrix organization less
number of genes were involved in alk in
cardiac myocytes ctcf and role of top in
t cell activation as shown in the figure
panther
protein analysis to evolutionary
relationship was used to classify
identify the function of these
integrated genes these genes were
introduced to panther results were in
the form of pie chart panther family
protein class molecular function
biological process cellular component
protein class and pathways of all the
genes identified using this here the
screenshot of the panther results are
calculated
and introduced
string search tool for the retrieval of
inter interacting genes protein is a
database that identify protein protein
interaction between the above mentioned
genes 19 proteins showed interaction
between each other string analysis was
performed for the 74 upregulated genes
to see protein protein interaction these
74
up regulated genes are common to at
least two data sets here nodes represent
protein and edges represent protein
protein interaction it shows which genes
are interconnected by their activity 19
genes showed interaction between each
other
number of nodes are 59 number of edges
are 42
cytoscape
these 19 proteins were introduced to
cytoscape to identify protein
interaction number of nodes and edges
and more information about the
interaction is collected
network from string database was
downloaded and uploaded in cytoscape for
further analysis this file from string
database was uploaded in cytoscape for
further analysis of the interaction
here we can see see how the genes are
connected notes
these
colored ones are the nodes and the line
are the edges and the edges show the
protein interaction between each node
that is the between each
other genes
it can be noted that only 19 genes
showed interaction between the each
other here the table represent the which
gene were interacted to which other gene
after using network analyzer tool in
cytoscape app the results can be seen in
the form of a table that contain name of
a gene between this
degree number of directed edges the
table is sorted from highest to lowest
degree
for all the for all the genes that were
connected that shows protein protein
interactions
g e p i a gene
gene expression profile interactive
analysis was performed
was performed for all the 13 genes
common to at least three
three data sets here disease-free
survival analysis was performed
the differentiate is considered
significant if adjusted p value is less
than 0.05 so only the genes f1 fn 1 and
dpp 4 were considered statistically
significant because their p value were
less than 0.05 rest all the genes out of
the 13 genes showed the
data didn't show statistically
significant add their as their p values
for more than 0.05
these are the disease-free survival
analysis for all the 13 genes
box plot for all the 13 upregulated
genes common to three data sets were
also performed using gep ia it shows
that the genes were differently
expressed in normal hydro tissue and
normal a tumor sample it was clarified
by analyzing the original data
discussion
different bioinformatics tool and
machine learning algorithm were used to
find up regularly differentially
expressed genes among the four data sets
differential expression analysis will be
formed in excel for all the four data
set by using
and uh by using the t test also using r
studios
uh
probe ids for match with the
corresponding g symbol offset plot was
prepared to find the interaction between
the eg's out of the is all 13 genes were
found to be common to at least three
data sets
using
david the g
geo terms and pathways where the genes
were analyzed and presented in the form
of
chart and table and using other
bioinformatic tools
it was used to predict the pathway
analysis
another protein protein interaction
disease free survival analysis and box
plot of all the
these 13 data sets data
these 13 genes
so these 13 genes can be used as
biomarkers with a thyroid cancer out of
these 13 genes four genes lpaf5 ilips hm
ga2 and lrp 1b work found to be
implicated in cancer proliferation the
these
we can we suggest that these four genes
to be potential targets for therapeutic
options
the
more information about these four genes
is collected here
so big data analysis was done to find
potential biomarkers for thyroid cancer
four genes lpar 5 lips hm ga2 and lr p1b
were found to be potential target for
therapeutic option their gene
neonatology pathways was
the related disease and their expression
and normal thyroid tissue and thyroid
cancer symbol have been studied in this
research paper this four genes are
related to cancer to cell proliferation
it was found that most of the regulated
genes were
involved in protein blinding plasma
membrane and integral component of
plasma membrane most of the upregulated
genes were involved in epithelial to
message timer transaction and colorectal
cancer tgf beta signaling partner
neutrophil degranulation extracellular
matrix organization these genes were
found to be upregulated in the data sets
for further analysis further analysis
can be done by proposing specific drugs
that target these genes by using
clinical methods many drugs can be
tested tested on these genes to see that
if that works drug inhibiting the
activity of these genes can be used for
treatment of treatment against thyroid
cancer
after precautions trans luminal coronary
angioplasty the majority of patients
have a
favorable favorable prognosis however in
passive tumors or distant metastases
might arise in a small percentage of
individual as a result identifying
critical indicators and therapeutic
targets for thyroid cancer will
significantly enhance patient
quality of life
here are the references
and thank you
[Music]